Kim Huskey: I have a sister who's making a
difference.
And her name is Kristine Huskey.
She is author of the recently published,
"Justice at Guantanamo: One woman's odyssey
and her crusade for human rights.”
She's an attorney, she's a law professor,
and she is codirector of the National Security
Clinic at the University of Texas School of
Law, which she established in 2007 and served
as director for two years.
So, I'll let her take over.
Thank you again for coming.
>> [Clapping]
Kristine Huskey: Oh, she does.
Well, thank you for that very warm welcome.
And special thanks to my sister and your colleague,
Kim Huskey.
She really is a great person.
And for her support in bringing me here and
to Google's support for bringing me here,
and to all of you for showing up -- whether
out of friendship for Kim or your interest
in the book.
So thank you.
So first, I'm going to tell you a little bit
about the book -- and you can all hear me,
right?
Tell you a little bit about the book, read
a passage -- maybe two -- depending on the
time, and then take questions.
So, what is the book about?
It's really two stories.
And the first story is my personal -- and
what some people might say "unconventional"
or some people might say "strange" -- journey
from being a reckless dancing-on-bars bartender
and model with my sister in New York City
to being part of a legal team before the Supreme
Court on a, you know, high-profile, very controversial,
internationally-known case that was being
heralded as one of the most significant human
rights -- civil rights -- cases since Brown
v. Board.
You could imagine how long and strange that
journey might have been.
The second story is the story of Guantanamo.
And it's not the story you might read in the
newspapers -- New York Times, Washington Post.
It's not the story you might read in a Harvard
Law Review with 300 footnotes.
So it's not a legal story; it's not a policy
story.
It's a story of Guantanamo from a human perspective
and from what it was like just a few years
out of law school really representing suspected
terrorists at Guantanamo having grown up in
Alaska with parents and grandparents who were
in the military.
And if asked, they probably would have said
they were Republicans -- and my sister is
rolling her eyes -- and all of a sudden, here
I was representing suspected terrorists.
So that's the second piece, and it's interwoven
with my personal journey.
It's really the human side -- hopefully the
human side -- of Guantanamo and how it started.
So the book opens with me 18 years old in
New York City, living with Kim in a basement
apartment, and I somehow move to Angola, Africa
-- 18 years old.
And Angola was in the middle of a raging civil
war.
I learned to live without running water, I
learned to speak Portuguese; there were curfews
and travel restrictions.
And the book starts with this 'high adventure'
-- hopefully, and kind of keeps the reader
through one adventure after another, talking
about my adventures there in Angola, and taking
me back to New York -- that's the reckless
part.
I will say, as an aside, my editor asked me
when I was writing that chapter, on New York,
"Can you put some more detail in there?”
And I said, "I'm a lawyer, and I might have
a career ahead of me.
So, we'll leave those details out.”
If you want more details, you can ask Kim
-- for the reckless details part.
So after really, a year of sort of "Bright
Lights, Big City" -- if anybody remembers
that movie -- I really pulled myself together,
inspired really by my sister to go to Columbia.
We went to Columbia, and we both graduated
with high honors.
And it sort of tells the story of what it's
like to live in New York City working, bartending,
putting yourself through school, trying to
make something of yourself really.
And then, my life sort of took another turn,
and I decided to model after graduating from
Columbia with high honors.
I guess maybe that's another part of the strange
journey.
And found myself modeling in videos.
And one, in particular -- again, some of you
might be too young to remember this, but -- there
was an MTV video called, "Knockin the Boots.”
Yeah, okay.
So I was in that video.
So that's really Part One of the book.
It's all those adventures, modeling, Columbia,
bartending, all these crazy things.
And finally, I decide to really be a professional.
And so, that's the majority of the book is
about my professional life as a lawyer and
about Guantanamo.
And so, I go into law school, of course, wanting
to save the world.
And I come out of law school, and what do
I do?
I work for a big law firm which represents
evil corporations -- as my sister used to
describe me -- and I did that for couple years,
and somehow found myself, shortly after starting
work at this law firm that's headquartered
here in New York, representing Guantanamo
detainees.
And this was more than seven years ago, and
just six months after 9/11, which, you know,
if anybody was in New York at the time probably
remembers it very vividly.
I was actually here on a case staying at the
Waldorf.
And I was at this law firm, and the law firm
was approached by a couple of Kuwaiti families
who were looking for their sons.
Now, if anybody remembers -- back then, Guantanamo
was a big secret.
And the administration wanted to keep it that
way.
And it was a legal black hole and there were
no lawyers allowed there and there were no,
you know, really no outside organizations
other than the Red Cross.
And any information that came out about Guantanamo
was, "Oh, these guys are all terrorists.
And they chew through hydraulic cable to kill
American men and women.”
Well, those were my clients.
And the Kuwaiti families basically said, "We
can't seem to find our sons who'd been overseas.
Nobody in the American embassy will talk to
us.
Nobody in the U.S. government will talk to
And so, we decided that we would have to file
a lawsuit against the U.S. government in order
to force the government to come forward and
just confirm that they had custody of these
Kuwaiti citizens.”
And so, we filed a lawsuit in May of 2002.
And I thought, you know, the lawsuit was basically,
"These guys deserve due process.
What about the Fifth Amendment?
They should have charges and trial."
And I thought, "Who can be against due process?
What judge is going to turn that down?”
We weren't asking them to be released.
We were just asking that they be charged,
given a trial, a chance to prove their innocence.
And you know, shockingly enough -- back then,
to me, it was shocking -- now, the world seems
to be somewhat different.
The judge agreed with the government.
And what the government said was not that
they don't get due process -- what the government
was saying is that Guantanamo is not the U.S.
and those men there are foreign citizens.
And so, not even the U.S. courts should be
overseeing the custody of these people who
are human beings -- that no U.S. court was
allowed to have authorization to hear claims
by these men.
And to me, that was just an astounding thing.
I mean, we wrote in this first brief -- we
said, "The government, essentially, is taking
the position that they could go around the
world and pick up people off the streets and
put them at Guantanamo and torture them.”
Well, actually, now we sort of know that's
what they did.
But back then, we sort of asked it as a rhetorical
question, "How could this possibly be?”
But the Court agreed with the government that
the men at Guantanamo should not even have
a right to be in court and challenge their
detention.
They didn't have a right to have a trial -- that
they could be tortured without even going
into court and complaining about it.
I mean, you know, either I was naive, or the
world really had changed.
I think more so -- as somebody mentioned,
Phil here -- that the U.S. changed, and we
were in a different time and in a different
place than the rest of the world.
So the book goes on -- the story goes on -- about
the litigation that I did and fighting in
the courts and as a young attorney, all of
a sudden finding myself at the Supreme Court
and doing these 'moots' -- they're called
'moots,' where you practice arguing -- you
know, with law professors.
And here I was just out of law school and
we're about to go in front of the Supreme
Court.
So that was, you know, it's from the book
and the story is from the eyes of a young
lawyer who's sort of taking this all in and
taking in what's going on, you know, at Guantanamo
and around the world.
Now, during that time, we were not allowed
to even meet with our clients or even talk
to them on the phone, because the government
had control of these people.
And it was sort of an eye opener for me.
What I realized was just really how much control
the government can have over the life of a
person.
And without, I think, people interjecting
or bringing litigation, they can just take
them to some, you know, Caribbean Island and
do whatever they want with them.
So that was sort of a big lesson for me to
learn how much control the government has.
So we get to the Supreme Court and, lo and
behold, we actually win.
And this is the well-known Rasul case that
came out in 2004 and was the first case in
which the Supreme Court said "The detainees
at Guantanamo are entitled to challenge their
detention.”
They are allowed to go into court and say,
"You've got the wrong guy.
You made a mistake." or, "The law doesn't
support me being here.”
And just, essentially, challenge their detention,
something that goes back to the Magna Carta,
which we -- I think, under the Bush Administration
-- had just really thrown to the side, this
idea of the rule of law.
So after the Supreme Court came out was the
first time we were then allowed to go visit
our clients in Guantanamo.
And so, the passage that I'm going to read
is about my first trip to Guantanamo two-and-a-half
years after beginning the representation of
them.
Okay.
[reading] Those first meetings with our clients
at Guantanamo in which we played the DVD from
their families, introduced ourselves to them,
and began the long process of getting to know
them were epic moments in my legal career
-- in my life.
It was unlike any other client meeting I'd
ever had.
Indeed, the last time I'd met with a client,
I'd been sitting at the bar of the Four Seasons
in New York, because I represented 'evil'
corporations.
Neil, Tom, and I – [talking] that was the
three people -- Neil and Tom are my colleagues
at the law firm of Shearman and Sterling who
are also on the legal team –
[reading resumed] Neil, Tom, and I had spent
more than two years of our lives working upon
behalf of these men that we'd never met, and
it felt strange to know 'of them', but not
to know them.
We were brought into an interview room at
Camp Echo -- this is at Guantanamo -- where
we found one of our clients sitting at a small
card table, handcuffed and chained to an O-ring
bolted to the floor.
Suddenly, seeing a real person in front of
me, I realized that until that moment, I'd
thought of our clients as a faceless group
-- the twelve Kuwaitis -- like some forgotten
religious order.
And they were forgotten, in a way.
Sometimes, I even thought of my client as
being the 'rule of law', as that was often
how I tried to explain my work to the press
and other audiences.
After meeting them, though, and putting faces
with names, I'd never be able to think of
them that way again.
They were people too.
And even though I'd known it all along, it
had become a distant fact after months filled
with litigation, when any rare time to myself
had been filled with enjoying my American
freedoms.
Meanwhile, these men -- my clients -- were
being held as criminals, accused of nothing,
and yet certainly suspected of much.
[talking] So that was the first trip to Guantanamo.
And thereafter, I would take at least 15 or
16 trips to Guantanamo.
The most recent being in April.
And every time I'd go, I'd learn something
new from my clients, whether they'd tell me
of some abuse they'd been through while they
were held in Bagram or in Guantanamo or I'd
be subject to some new rule.
You know, one time -- in the beginning of
those visits -- we were allowed to go to the
public library on the base; and then thereafter,
we weren't allowed to go to the public library.
We were never explained why.
But this whole process was teaching me so
much about, again, the power of the government,
and how it affects real people.
And that was something that I learned sort
of in that moment was, the rule of law is
so important to us as -- in America this idea
of the rule of law.
And we sort of talk about it and Obama talked
about it a lot.
But the import of that is that, it affects
real people -- real human beings.
And it protects us, as well as people who
are at Guantanamo, who are foreign citizens.
But I think the hardest visits that I had
at Guantanamo were when my clients were on
hunger strike.
And they were hunger striking for a couple
of reasons.
One, they were hunger striking to protest
their conditions.
They felt they were not being treated humanely.
And indeed, in the beginning of their stay
at Guantanamo, I learned that they had exercise
20 minutes a week.
That they weren't allowed any reading materials
except for the Quran, which actually wasn't
even provided to them until several months
after they'd been there.
That they'd been subject to interrogation,
sleep deprivation, hot and cold extremes.
That they really were treated not like 'suspected'
terrorists, but like terrorists.
And they'd never had a trial.
And this went on for a very long time, this
sort of treatment.
So I learned all of this.
They were protesting that.
They were also protesting just the fact that
they had not been charged.
And I had this one client who used to say,
"Just give my a trial.
Just give me the chance to prove that I'm
innocent.”
And people used to ask me at that time, "You
know, are your clients innocent?”
And I said, "Well, give them a trial, and
we'll find out.
If they're not innocent, we'll hang them up
by their toes.”
But the whole point is to let them try to
prove their innocence.
The whole point is to have a process whereby
you sort out the guilty from the innocent.
And that was always what we were litigating
about and what the Guantanamo detainees were
protesting about.
So they went on this hunger strike.
At the height of the hunger strike, there
were probably 150 detainees on hunger strike,
not eating, protesting their conditions and
the lack of trial.
So, next passage is from that experience,
which was really quite traumatic for me, and
I wasn't even on hunger strike.
[reading] I thought about Fouzi -- one of
my clients -- and the other hunger strikers
who said they would rather die than eat.
What that meant for Fouzi was -- if he got
his way, if his feeding tube was removed and
he continued his hunger strike -- he would
die.
And by the looks of him, I didn't think it
would take very long.
It was pretty obvious to me that the only
thing keeping him alive was that feeding tube
and he wanted to be rid of it.
[talking] As an aside, the Guantanamo health
professionals had basically forced them to
eat, because they didn't want them to die.
Meanwhile, they were torturing them on the
side.
So a lot of the detainees were subject to
feeding tubes.
[reading resumed] We were his lawyers.
We were supposed to be working on his behalf,
in his best interest.
Shouldn't we be petitioning the court to stop
the force feeding?
"If Fouzi wants to die," I said back in D.C.,
behind the closed doors of Tom's office -- again,
Tom was the law partner I worked with on this
case -- "we should let him die.”
I was devastated, but firmly believed that
it should be Fouzi's right to determine his
fate should he decide to see his hunger strike
through to the end.
It had only been a week since we'd been back
from Guantanamo, and the shock of seeing five
of our clients on hunger strike, two of them
dangerously close to death or serious illness,
had not left either of us.
Tom didn't want to see Fouzi die either and
was just as determined to save him.
"That's not what the families want, Kristine,"
Tom said.
"I know, Tom, but who's our client here?
Is it Fouzi or his family?
What about what Fouzi wants?”
"What are we going to do?
Ask the Court to let him die?”
Tom was shouting.
I shouted back, "Who are you to decide what's
best for Fouzi?
Who made you God?”
And suddenly, I was crying too.
And Tom jumped up to hug me.
Now, mind you, something -- this is a 'no
no'.
In a big law firm, you don't do that, but
Tom and I were human, and we were upset.
Tom and I both knew that we had an ethical
obligation to do as our client wished, and
yet, we couldn't bring ourselves to be the
ones to seal Fouzi's fate -- a slow death
in a cell at the Guantanamo Bay Detention
Center.
Had we known we'd be having a conversation
of this magnitude when we first met with the
Kuwaiti families, in which someone's life
was in our hands, maybe we wouldn't have agreed
to take their case.
But there we were, neck-deep in a case that
seemed impossible at every turn where every
decision we made seemed to have either substantial
consequences or no impact at all on somebody
else's welfare.
It was just getting to us.
[talking] I think, now is a good time to answer
questions.
Oh, yes. You must use that microphone.
You must use that microphone.
Somebody must have some question.
Kim, you're supposed to -- oh, sorry -- yes.
>> [pause]
Q Testing. If you had to guess, What percentage
of the prisoners that you saw at Guantanamo
bay would you say were guilty?
Kristine Huskey: Well, now, that's a good
question.
I mean, like I said, in the beginning when
I first started this representation, a lot
of people asked, you know, "Are they guilty?
Are they innocent? Are your clients?”
You know, the truth is, in some ways all that
-- the seven years of litigation -- was always
about whether or not the courts even had the
authority to hear these claims, right?
So it wasn't until recently that the lawyers
were even allowed to ask for discovery of
the evidence, which was supposed to prove
that they were guilty or not guilty.
So it's really only in the last year that
lawyers who represent the detainees are actually
getting documents, you know, notes of interrogations
and such like that.
So from sort of a practical standpoint, if
you'd ask me that question a year ago, I would
have said, "I have no idea.”
But the truth is -- So, since in the last
year -- they're called habeas cases, right?
'Habeas' means the right to challenge your
detention, the writ of habeas in our Constitution,
not to be suspended.
There have been 33 actual habeas cases, which
means the lawyers went in and tried to prove
that they were innocent and the government
went in and tried to prove they were guilty.
Out of the 33, 28 federal judges granted the
writ of habeas, which means that they are
innocent.
So I mean, that's a sort of astounding statistic.
I think another interesting point to follow
up on that is, you know, back -- again when
I'm saying back in 2002 when they were talking
about "All these terrorists at Guantanamo,"
this, that, and the other -- eventually it
came out, based on the Department of Defense's
own statistical information that only five
percent of the people at Guantanamo -- and
at that time it was about 400 -- five percent
had actually been picked up by U.S.
forces.
The other 95 percent were picked up by Pakistani
officials -- either military, or even just
police.
Some had been turned over by villagers or
Northern Alliance or Afghan local authorities.
So I think that's a big, you know -- when
you ask the question, "How many are guilty?”
You start with that sort of statistic, and
you think about, How can it be that with that
chain of custody in mind, that every single
person who's at Guantanamo is guilty of terrorism?
Of course, as a good lawyer, I would never
tell you what I think about my clients.
[laughter]
>> [pause]
Q Yeah. I wonder if it even matters at all
if any of them are guilty.
Because that's not really the fundamental
issue.
I mean, it's really unfortunate for some of
the individuals if they happen to be innocent
and they're there, but there's a small number
of them.
The real problem to me seems to be that the
system has changed.
When I was a kid, I grew up mainly overseas.
We were always being attacked by people for
being Americans and the rest.
Well, my parents were always able to tell
me, you know,
"We don't start wars without provocation.
We treat prisoners well. We don't torture.”
This whole long list of things that -- even
if we were being criticized for things -- you
could still hold your head up for being an
American, because being an American stood
for something.
Unfortunately, I have a daughter today who
comes to me and asks me questions about the
country, and I can't tell her the same things
my parents told me.
Something changed fundamentally at Guantanamo,
also Abu Ghraib and some other such things.
But Guantanamo was a really important one
in that, sort of, our expectations of what
we do in conflicts are now different.
It used to be, you'd have a war, you get prisoners,
and there were some rules in prisoners.
You can't photograph them.
You've got to treat them nice.
You let their officers have a role in the
community.
Basically, you're just warehousing them until
the conflict is over and then you send them
home.
And you're not allowed to torture them.
And you got to feed them well and all the
rest. That sort of stuff.
At least those were the rules that we had.
But now, we're making the distinction between
what's a 'prisoner of war' and what's a 'terrorist'.
And terrorists, apparently, we can do strange
things to that we couldn't do to prisoners
of war.
And guys who seem like they should have been
prisoners of war are being terrorists etc.
Anyway, you all went to court.
You had a bunch of things changed.
But, what were you not able to fix?
How is our system different today after Guantanamo
than it was before?
What have we lost?
Kristine Huskey: Well, you raise many good
points and some which I should have hit on
in the beginning talking about Guantanamo.
You know, one of the original problems of
Guantanamo -- like I said -- was, it was a
legal black hole.
And what that really meant was, the Bush Administration
was saying, "They're not prisoners of war.
And so, the Geneva Conventions don't apply,
which are the set of international rules which
sort of govern how we treat prisoners when
we're in a conflict.
And they're terrorists, but they're at Guantanamo,
so Federal U.S. law doesn't apply.
And you're right.
I mean, the issue -- the real issue -- is
that, you know, Guantanamo has sort of become
a symbol for how the U.S. has changed.
I don't know if the world -- I think the world
has changed some, with respect to how we look
at terrorism, preventive detention, the laws
of war.
But, I think the U.S. changed the most, in
part because of 9/11.
So, the issue has become -- and it's an issue
now that's being debated by the Obama administration
-- that's something I think we all need to
think about.
Do we sort of go back to pre-9/11 and we say,
"Listen, if they're accused of being terrorists,
we have criminal laws that we've used in our
courts -- in New York actually several terrorism
cases, and they were convicted.
And they're serving in maximum security prisons.”
And that's sort of the pre-9/11 paradigm.
Or do we have something that -- as I mentioned
as being sort of contemplated -- is this idea
that you could have suspected terrorists who
aren't charged with terrorism.
They're not in a law-of-war paradigm, because
they're not really in a traditional armed
conflict.
And so, therefore we will detain them, because
we're afraid they might commit some terrorist
act.
And that is what's being -- as I said -- seriously
considered by the Obama administration.
So that, I think, is what has changed fundamentally.
Is this idea that we no longer can apply the
traditional laws of war.
We possibly can't apply our U.S. criminal
laws, antiterrorism laws.
And we're sort of now in this kind of middle
course contemplating holding people, because
we 'think' they might do something bad or
wrong.
And they're grappling with, Are there laws
that support that?
So, go back to I think your second, or maybe
third, question.
You know, What didn't we fix?
Well, a lot. A lot.
There's still people at Guantanamo, although,
you know, thankfully Obama came out and said
he's going to close Guantanamo.
But I think that's sort of the biggest piece,
you know?
The biggest piece is that somehow maybe we
weren't able to show -- to demonstrate -- how
terrible it is to have a legal black hole.
How terrible it is not to have laws that apply,
such that they're now seriously considering
preventive detention. You know?
And I agree with you.
In the beginning, we used to talk about, How
could this be that we do not have the application
of some kind of law here?
Because what brings us together in America
as citizens and residents, you know, is not
that we have Coke and Levi's -- although that's
certainly an American thing -- but it was
being so proud of our system, our democracy,
our justice system.
We have one of the best justice systems in
the world.
And you know, now that's changed.
You know? That's changed.
>> [pause]
Q Hi. You've talked a little bit about how
this whole experience made you realize just
how much power the government has.
And how long it took for the courts to come
through and say, "Yes, the law does apply
to these people.”
Years and years and years.
So, I'm curious what your thoughts are -- and
you can talk a little bit about -- what you
feel that the role of the courts 'should be'
versus what 'it is'.
Whether you think they should have more power
to affect what the president's doing, whether
they should be able to act more quickly as
opposed to kind of the glacial pace they move
at now.
Whether they should have jurisdiction over
more areas like these kind of legal black
hole areas that they don't seem to be able
to touch.
That's kind of open-ended.
Kristine Huskey: No. I mean, as a young lawyer,
when I started doing this litigation, it was
-- every step of the way was sort of eye-opening.
And starting at the lower court and finally
making your way up to the Supreme Court.
You know, as you said, everything sort of
moved so glacially.
And I just thought, "Geez," you know?
"Even if we win, it will be two-and-a-half
years later.
And these guys will spend an important part
of their life there.”
So part of me says, "It should be faster.
The courts should have more power.
They should be able to do something faster."
But another part of me really respects that
it is -- part of it is such a slow process
because the goal is to let each party take
the time to brief everything and look at the
law and for the judge to ponder it, give the
government a chance to possibly change its
ways or put forward its reasoning.
And then you have the whole system of appeals,
which -- in our case -- that was terrible.
It sucked.
"Oh, we got to go to appeal.”
But if you think about it from the reverse,
if you were -- let's say you were convicted
of something and you were innocent.
And you were maybe sentenced to the death
penalty, you would want all those -- you want
a chance to keep appealing and appealing.
So, I guess I go sort of both ways.
I agree with you, "Oh, it's too slow."
But at the same time, I really do have great
respect for our justice system which really
seems to give an opportunity to find the truth.
And sometimes finding the truth can take a
long time, because you give a chance for all
parties to weigh in.
And then you go to the next court.
And then you do it all over again, and you
go to the next court.
So a good example, while we were going up
to the Supreme Court -- sorry, after the Supreme
Court -- and the Supreme Court had ruled and
we were going to Guantanamo, we learned all
these things about -- they wanted to have
more reading materials and they wanted to
have more exercise.
And then, they wanted to have this sort of
scholarly commentary on the Quran.
And we petitioned the court for all this.
And basically -- because the government said,
"No way.
They don't get that. They don't get that.
Nope, nope, nope.”
And the court -- you know what the court did?
It just ignored our motions.
Which was devastating.
Devastating.
Q Hi. Thanks a lot.
This is very fascinating stuff.
Kristine Huskey: Thank you.
Q Couple of questions.
Do you think there are other black holes like
this in the world?
Because I would certainly suspect that there
are.
And to address earlier comments about believing
in America and 'all things American' being
good, I grew up in that sort of, you know
-- as the offspring of the Golden Generation
of the United States and believing all those
things -- but Vietnam pretty much nailed that
box shut for me.
With recent events like Laura Ling and Euna
Lee with North Korea, the hikers in Iraq/Iran,
other taking of individuals.
Do you think the U.S. was using Guantanamo
Bay as sort of a collection of bargaining
chips?
Like, "We're going to gather a bunch of people
and use them if we need to, to negotiate some
sort of balance."?
Kristine Huskey: I mean, there definitely
was -- at some point what they had -- what
they were called the CIA 'black sites', where
they did bring -- and this sort of came out
after Guantanamo had come out, right?
And so, we're looking at Guantanamo like,
"Oh, it's this legal black hole.”
And then we find out there's sites that are
even more of a legal black hole than Guantanamo.
Which is just, "What?!" you know?
And then it was during the Bush Administration
that he said he was going to shut them down.
And actually, before -- in 2006, Congress
passed a law about the military commissions
-- and, you know, what I think was in sort
of a manipulative move -- moved a lot of the
detainees from these 'black sites' to Guantanamo
and said to Congress, "Okay.
Now you have to pass this law, because now
all these high-value detainees are there,
and they should be put through some sort of
system.”
You know, throughout the seven-and-a-half
years that I've been litigating and representing
detainees and working on these issues, every
time something happens -- you know, when Abu
Ghraib came out and the black sites, you say,
"Oh, it can't get any worse.
There can't be another breaking news story
about what this government is doing with national
security and our rights.”
But then it came out that they were wiretapping
American citizens, you know.
So I'm sort of very happy with how the book
ended, because it ends with the Obama administration
coming in and I say, you know, I have hope
-- of course, that's his catch phrase -- but
so, I hope that we don't have those black
sites anymore.
But in some ways, you can't really be sure
until you sort of find out.
I think -- whether or not Guantanamo was a
bargaining chip.
I would say during the Bush administration,
it probably was, to some degree.
I feel, for me, I'm still sort of waiting
to see what the Obama administration does,
how they handle certain things.
I think they're scrambling.
Most recently, they were supposed to come
out with a report on how they're going to
handle the detainees at Guantanamo.
What they were going to do with them.
Whether or not they would have some sort of
preventive detention.
And they -- basically, the task force came
out and said, "It's going to be delayed.
It's going to be another six months.”
Which in another six months Guantanamo is
supposed to be shut down.
So I think it really remains to be seen what
the administration is going to do with a lot
of these issues.
Hope I answered your question. Thank you.
Q Sort of affiliated to some of the previous
questions.
What is your experience and opinion about
how all this affected the international opinion
about the U.S. justice system both technically
-- so, What are the laws?
Or What have U.S. changed?
And more like politically or perceptionwise?
And related to this -- it's a technical question,
because I don't know anything about law -- when
in 2002, the judge agreed with the government
that they cannot be sued in U.S. Court, did
you consider suing the United States in International
Court?
Kristine Huskey: We did. I mean, the international
book from the legal and the policy perspective
is very interesting.
I think, from just a policy perspective -- and
I've traveled overseas a lot, for my business
and also just for fun -- the response from
the international community, I think, has
largely been disappointment, disbelief, you
know, the U.S. used to hold itself out as
the champion of human rights.
And people would say, "You know, how can we
hold our heads up?”
It was something that was mentioned earlier.
And the international community -- again,
from a policy perspective -- was like, "Now
you can't really tell us what to do." Right?
From a legal perspective, there's been just
a lot of criticism about the numerous violation
of international treaties by the United States.
I mean, they've signed on to the torture against
convention.
They've signed on to the Convention of the
Rights of the child.
And, lo and behold, the U.S. had several children
under the age of 16 at Guantanamo detained
with adult people.
They signed on to the International Covenant
of Civil and Political Rights.
And that, quite honestly, just -- and I think
the Bush Administration really, quite frankly,
didn't give a damn about international law.
And it just sort of went out the window.
But a lot of international lawyers were very
concerned, because the U.S. was always a leader
in international law in getting other countries
to sign on to these treaties that were so
important, right?
And the interesting thing about sort of the
international aspect of it is that -- from
what I hear.
This is a little bit of gossip and rumor -- many
U.S. officials who were in power during the
Bush administration are afraid to travel overseas,
because there's this concept of 'universal
jurisdiction', which means if you've committed
war crimes and you're in a country that believes
in universal jurisdiction, the Spanish authorities
can arrest you and put you in a trial in their
courts.
And so, I hear that a lot of the U.S. Bush
officials will not travel to Italy or Spain
or anywhere in the E.U.
And recently, Italy indicted eight CIA agents
-- they were not in Italy at the time, but
they basically sort of put out a E.U.-wide
warrant for their arrest, saying these eight
CIA agents were in Italy and I think kidnapped
individuals and brought them to either, you
know, Bagram or Guantanamo or one of these
other black sites.
Did I answer your second question?
Okay. Thank you.
>> [pause]
Q I have one follow up question to the previous
question.
So, you mentioned that Guantanamo was this
black hole of a kind, and you hope that there
would be no more black holes like these.
But, when you look at it, it seems essentially
that, after 9/11, it turned out that the Constitution
and the laws are more or less quite malleable
in the sense that you can justify quite a
lot of things by saying, you know, the executive
branch basically has the right to do quite
a lot of things.
And I just wonder if you feel there's anything
which could be done to amend this system to
make sure that things like this could not
happen in the future?
Because while there was a Supreme Court decision
which made some progress, but essentially,
it seems like these things -- there isn't
like a black wall put in the past which would
guarantee that such things couldn't occur
in the future.
Kristine Huskey: No, that's, I mean, one of
the big criticisms of the Bush Administration
-- among others -- was the sort of abuse
of executive power.
And they sort of became inflated with this
idea that Bush was the executive.
"It's a national security crisis, I can do
anything.”
But I think they really took it quite far.
And they had lawyers who would write long
legal opinions -- just like you said -- about
how it was justified, how it really was legal,
and that it wasn't a violation of the Constitution.
Well, you could take the view of Shakespeare
who said, "Kill all the lawyers.
Then you wouldn't have legal opinions backing
that up.”
But -- that was a joke -- but, you're right.
It's both a problem and a great thing about
this country though is, we have the Constitution,
which has been called -- it's a 'living document',
right? which means that it changes with the
time.
Some of the Supreme Court opinions, you know,
about discrimination are vastly different
from 1918 in the Dred Scott case to Brown
v Board.
So the fact that it's not 'hard and fast'
has allowed great things in this country,
but at the same time has allowed terrible
things to happen.
So, I think it is in many ways something that
points to, We have to really hold officials
accountable, because I think that's really
the solution.
I don't know that we could pass a law that
would change the Constitution.
In some ways, I think that might come back
to hurt us to have a hard and fast rule.
I think it means holding officials -- whether
it's your state representative or your representative
on the Hill in Washington to the President
-- holding them accountable as a people.
Because the Constitution is supposed to protect
us, not the executive branch.
So I know that doesn't sound like a very easy
solution, but I think in some ways to me,
that would be my preferred solution.
>> I think we're going to wrap it up.
Kristine is going to hang around if you want
to ask her some more questions, or she can
sign your book if you'd like.
But thank you, everybody, for coming.
>> [Clapping]
Kristine Huskey: Thank you.